well hello everyone thank you very much
a deep for taking part in this in this
course on faith and globalization Thank
You first of all for not sniggering when
I was introduced as a professor like
last year's class did which means that
you are either a more courteous or be
less specific but I wanted to thank very
much
Miroslav for his incredible
collaboration with me which I've really
enjoyed and dug for what is a
fascinating introduction leaving it a
bit up in the air there at the end you
know Huntington basically it's the end
of the world or is it I don't know times
run out we'll come back to that later
so first of all let me just a few words
about about the foundation I started
Tony Blair faith foundation because I
believe for the reasons that I'll give
you in a moment that faith matters is of
fundamental importance to understanding
the modern world and but also because I
I had a more subjective desire in mind
as well which is to stress the value of
faith in the modern world and how faith
could be a a force for progress and for
reason and for conflict resolution
rather than division sectarianism
violence and so on it's partly also
because I think for a lot of people
today they they yearn for spirituality
they don't always find it an organized
religion they don't always find it in
the in the way that organized religion
behaves so I think this the concept of
faith and its place in the world today's
fundamental importance may seem odd the
reason former political leader to say
that but you know what's strange is very
often people I I meet outside politics
think it's a little bizarre that I've
taken up this as a major part of my new
life funnily enough former colleagues I
speak to who are political leaders think
it's entirely sensible and that's
because they're dealing with real-life
situation
every day in which these issues to do
with faith and actually faith and
globalization matter
now for this Yale course we wanted to
create an academic course that dealt
with these these issues and dealt them
with them knowledge and faith is about
theology and then you've got you know
your grand strategies and political
affairs and the two things in separate
we wanted to bring them together we
thought that there is a necessary study
there of how the to interrelate and this
is the second year we've done this at
Yale but now we're doing this in other
universities throughout the world and
our desire in the end is to build up a
core group of 12 internationally
renowned universities where this course
is taught and then we want a whole lot
of things to spin off from that so you
guys and you know you're part of
something at the beginning but believe
me it's gonna be big in the end and so
there is the National University of
Singapore that is that is now taking
this up in Durham in the UK there's
other universities in Canada actually
we're in discussion with universities in
China now and in other parts of the
world and we want this to be a genuinely
global course and the fascinating thing
is that we are finding no closed doors
very open doors and if anything
competition in different countries as to
who should come and participate in this
and I'm not arrogant enough to think
this is to do with me I actually think
it's to do with the fact that if you
take any day's news and look through the
newspapers you can see the issues to do
with faith and politics and how it
interrelates to an increasingly global
community their manifest now so my basic
view is if you can't understand the
world of faith today whether you're in
business or in public affairs or in
politics you actually can't understand
the world that's the importance of the
course now just to demonstrate this we
we had some slides that we put together
which are just very few of them but I'll
run you through them because it's a
basic factual
substratum if you like to this to this
debate and leads on quite neatly from
what Doug and miroslav have just been
saying five billion people in the world
own up to some form of religious
affiliation actually as the world's
population increases so will the numbers
of Christians and Muslims and Hindus and
others but the other thing that is
interesting is the dramatic increase in
international migration in other words
what's happening is the world is is
moving closer together and that is
basically as I say in a moment what
globalization does and then if you look
at the next slide which has taken from
the Gallup poll about the importance of
religion and it's a little difficult to
see from parts of this but actually what
this shows you the darker parts the most
religious you might be quite surprised
to look at a less religious place that
is the United States of America but that
is only relative when the polling was
done on how important was religion to
your life is it important or very
important the figures actually I think
were quite remarkable in the UK and in
Europe it was just over 30% where some
people said well that's not much
actually if you think of a third of the
population thinks religion is important
or very important than their lives is
really quite a lot in America the
figures just over 60% but in many parts
of the developing world and say Brazil
and Africa the Christians but really
throughout the Muslim world the figures
are over 90%
now that's shows you I think if you
think of a country in which over 90
percent of the population is saying
religion is important or very important
to me I think you make the case fairly
easily that religion matters actually
not surveyed in this was China and I'll
say some words about that in a moment
because I actually think what's
happening in respect of religion and
China is also interesting and then
you get the two sides of it religion for
good or for bad
you see increasingly negative views for
example of Jews in Europe and of Muslims
in Europe what is quite interesting I
think about this is that in Britain than
in the u.s. which we might expect this
to be different actually the negative
views of Muslims are less than in other
parts of Europe which i think is quite
interesting but so in some of the
Western countries there are some
developing hostile views towards those a
particular religious face
but the other thing is if you look at
religious conflict actually there are
not many conflicts in the world today in
which religion is not playing a part or
at least is something of a dimension and
I think it's virtually impossible to
look and certainly any of the points of
conflict in the Middle East without
understanding the importance that
religion plays in those conflicts and
yet as we saw from the conference
actually we held yesterday here which
was about faith-based organizations
helping in development and global
poverty faith-based organizations also
do immense good so you see a lot of the
the better educational outcomes
healthcare outcomes that have been
delivered in some of the poorest parts
of the world are being delivered by
faith-based organizations so the
conclusion of that is regardless of your
own belief system background
intellectual interest and future plans
to understand the world in which we live
you need to understand religion and then
a quote from the chief rabbi of the UK
Jonathan Sacks the world face a global
phenomena whose reach is broader in some
respects deeper than the nation-state so
that's kind of my way of why what why is
this important why should we be worried
about it and let me pick up on some of
the things that mirror slapping and Doug
were just saying
globalization is a term that we we use
to cover many things but I I sometimes
think in certainly practical political
life it's best to try and keep things
relatively simple because actually your
understanding is then greater really
what globalization is doing is it's just
it's pushing the world together now you
can debate that and some people will say
well it's not really and something will
qualify it by saying this and saying
that but actually that is really what's
happening and it is a hugely powerful
voice and force I mean it's transforming
societies and countries it has enormous
opportunities and it has drawbacks and
dangers but the thing that I think is
most important of all to say about
globalization is that it is driven by
people there is a misconception
sometimes that globalization is a force
essentially driven by government
actually it's not if you look at what's
driving globalization which is the
internet mass communication mass travel
the thing that brings a lot of you from
different parts of the world here in
Yale its choice people are making
choices so it's people that are driving
this force of globalization and that is
very important incidentally because if
government is doing something against
the will of the people it can often be
eventually stopped but the will of the
people is very hard to stop and it is
individual choices by individual people
that is producing this process of
globalization which just to give you an
example of how that then changes
countries and societies when we did the
the bid for Britain to win the the right
to host the Olympics in 2012 we have to
make a presentation as a country and it
was one of these interesting moments
where you have to stand back and think
of how you're going to sum up your own
country near a city it was London that
was bidding and the first presentation I
was given it was very much about
you know London [ __ ] palaces of
parliament the you know all the rich
history of Britain and so on and so
forth
and when I thought about it and thought
about the London in which my kids were
growing up I thought actually you know
that is not the most interesting thing
about that's the most obvious thing
about London on the most interesting
thing the most interesting thing is
London is today a place where you have
people from different races cultures
ethnic backgrounds and they mix together
and they lived together and actually
basically they thrive together pretty
much and interestingly when we had
literally the day after we won the
Olympic bid the the terrorist acts in
London and bonds the interesting there
was the response of Londoners was to
come together not to fall apart which
was a reaction that was produced by the
fact that actually most people were
living and working alongside each other
and coexisting peacefully but it was an
interesting reflection on the type of
country we've been and that you know
that's the force of globalization
I mean London major financial center
major meeting place for people that's
what globalization is doing it's pushing
people together now when that happens
there is a natural reaction because with
it comes an almost change you know and
actually Britain again as an example of
this back in the 1950s and 1960s when we
started to get immigration and
immigration not from white people but
got immigration from black people it
caused trouble and difficulties how much
that five minutes
I'm not in charge am i you're in charge
okay
and right have to speed up a little bit
and but what happened was I mean in the
end we over overcame that that's fear
but what is that about and it's the same
process with globalization now it's fear
because if there's change it's fear
because there's a sense of loss of
control right things are that our usual
book Apple replaced by things that are
unusual or different but most of all
it's the loss of identity people feel
that they're what how they felt
themselves and how they felt the
community and society around them has
changed and people then feel in the
faith sense that my truth and the truth
that I've grown up with is suddenly
challenged because your truth comes
alongside it and what this does this
force of globalization if therefore
forces us also to confront the nature of
our faith and I want to suggest you that
religion has three coexisting elements
religious faith that sometimes are
combined but sometimes you can see very
distinctly this first religion is
tradition this is how we grew up
right our parents were this way we're
this way you know it can be a bit like
voting patterns yeah because my parents
voted this way I've always voted this
way this is our vote so it's tradition
religion is just part of basic tradition
the secondly religion has identity and
this is really I think the concern that
underlay the Huntington thesis the
religion identifies me it makes me makes
me feel that I belong right it's how I
identify myself I am a Christian I am a
Muslim and a Hindu that's how I identify
myself but then it's a third aspect
which is faith around certain values and
what is interesting there is that faith
around certain values tends to be values
there are common across the face and
people share and then personally I think
most people if they decide their haven't
grown up by tradition they don't see it
as a matter of identity but they make a
conscious choice to become religious
most people do so because there are
certain values in the faith that appeal
to them so my father in fact was a
convinced atheist and still is I mean if
we get on fine these could've been story
too but so I know it's great acts of
rebellion but any hope it doesn't affect
Mike to the other way but it's you know
that thought for me the reason I was
drawn I was drawn to Christianity at the
same time was drawn to politics but I
was drawn not on the basis of some piece
of the theological my new she I but
because I felt that the Christian faith
represented as it did to me at its best
compassion love of neighbor a belief in
social justice that that drew me in this
what I would call religion is values now
it's often a mixture of all of those
things people can be religious because
because of tradition because of identity
and because of values but I think when
you look at how people behave as people
of faith towards people of other faiths
then it becomes quite important which is
the predominant view that you have of
why you are a religious person and
that's why you know for example
sometimes people used to say to me in
respect of Northern Ireland and they say
it also in respect of the work I do now
in Israel Palestine they say it's not
religious this dispute is going to do
with religion and I said well that's a
bit strange because I'm afraid of the
people engaged in this dispute think it
has and you know it can't be entirely
coincidental that this group of
Protestant this group of Catholic when
I'm in my office in Jerusalem now and I
just look out of the window and I'm
right on the edge between East and West
Jerusalem you know you see the people in
very obviously Orthodox Jewish grab you
see the people very obviously who are
Muslim and then the women particularly
dressed
in in the way that they choose to do as
Muslims so religion matters it can be
for good or for ill it can pull us apart
or it can be a force for good and it
relates to globalization also in this
way that this force of globalization as
it pushes us together the question is
does faith become then a force that
pulls you apart or can it in fact be a
force that does the opposite that
because of values to do with love of
neighbor a sense of justice a sense of
community a sense of the other can it be
not just a for peaceful coexistence but
also a humanizing force for the process
of globalization itself so can it teach
us through love of neighbor to respect
difference and can it teach us through
values the globalization without justice
will lead to pain and misery for the
majority and even war right final thing
final final thing I spent a week in
China recently and it's very interesting
I mean it's a fascinating an exciting
place to be of course what is
interesting is that there is this huge
process of economic development going on
hundreds and millions of people have got
to be lifted from poor farming
subsistence farming sixty percent of the
population still and probably got to be
lifted into an industrialized economy
and the concern of China obviously is
that the gap now between an East Coast
that is very wealthy and an interior
Western subsistence economy on farming
that gap is very broad so you can see
globalization at work there very easily
I mean it's going on every day every
city every town interesting thing is
especially now 60 years into the
People's Republic of China the 1949
revolution is a sense the people in
China want to see their history not just
as the 60 years of the revolution but as
the thousands of years of the
civilization but I did and what you find
increasingly in speeches made by Chinese
leaders are I was at a conference down
as one of the poorer provinces in grigio
and place called GUI yang listening to
speeches it was interesting the number
of speakers we were talking about the
environment actually in climate change
who mentioned the traditions of Buddhism
and Taoism and Confucianism the governor
of the province was a Muslim right the
discussions I were having were also to
some people who were Christians now that
I think is an interesting closing point
for the to begin our discussion that you
faith does matter the force of
globalization is driven by people it is
pushing the world together the question
is does faith become the means of
reaction or the means of progress and
this concept of faith answers something
very deep within people which contrary
to what people might have thought in the
West is not diminishing in the era of
globalization in other words this idea
that as people get better off or they
start to globalize on and industrialize
that they give up on faith on the
contrary
people's deep-seated yearning for some
spiritual dimension for some grounding
of this protec anomic process and some
values is actually profound real and if
anything increasing rather than
diminishing